[Applaudissements]
il tousse détendu mais tout ça il ya un
petit côté complexe de dieu dans
l'intelligence artificielle ya un petit
côté prométhée ou victor frankenstein
prenez le machine learning même si vous
savez pas ce que c'est c'est pas grave
mais chez marni c'est formidable c'est
un ensemble d'algorithmes qui existent
tout seul un algorithme temps qui lui
tout seul li complètement idiot et c'est
nous qui allons nourrir avec des données
pour le rendre intelligent on va lui
demander d'observer le monde qui est
contenu dans les données qu'on lui
fournit de se l'approprier pour pouvoir
le reproduire et d'anticiper je vous
donne un exemple
l'intelligence artificielle au début
elles existent tout seul tant qu'elle
est toute seule elle sait rien faire
je veux lui montrer des gens malades si
on peut beaucoup de gens malades et au
bout d'un moment elle sera capable de
détecter un cancer avant un être humain
de détecter un cancer avant un être
humain vous savez que le cancer plutôt
on ne détecte plus on a de chance de le
guérir avec l'intelligence artificielle
on peut sauver le monde
oui je vous assure je m'appelle anna jeu
mathématicienne spécialiste de
l'intelligence artificielle et oui je
suis féministe
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé à travailler une
entreprise m'a demandé de leur
développer une intelligence artificielle
en gros pour épier les gens sur les
réseaux sociaux et prédire les sources
potentielles de manifestations et de
contre-pouvoirs on pourrai je parle
sauver le monde mais non non c'est ça
qu'on va faire on va prendre toutes les
dispositions et écrite
et puis au lieu de les considérer comme
des avertissements
on va les utiliser comme des modes
d'emploi alors fait savoir que c'était
le type de poste
excessivement bien payés et honnêtement
scientifiquement techniquement c'est
intéressant mais bon humainement
moralement éthiquement
c'était ma première leçon l'intelligence
artificielle elle n'est pas neutre je
vois une
différentes ici ça m'a perturbé
l'intelligence artificielle n'est pas
notre intelligence artificielle elle
peut être développée à mauvais escient
je vous ai dit qu'on pouvait on a la
capacité de construire un monde meilleur
ça veut dire qu'on a la responsabilité
de le faire
moi j'ai pu refuser cette offre
c'est une chance c'est un luxe que tout
le monde a pas j'ai été embauché en tant
qu'ingénieur de recherche à l'université
la moitié du salaire
je me suis intéressé aux véhicules
autonomes le véhicule autonome
d'abord techniquement c'est hyper
intéressant ya beaucoup de challenges et
surtout il ya un enjeu de société
moi je viens d'un village en corse si tu
peux pas conduire
tu peux rien faire pour moi le véhicule
autonome
c'était permettre à mon mois à 15 ans
d'aller à la plage c'était désenclaver
des territoires c'était redonner de la
mobilité à toute une partie de la
population
puis je fais l'intelligence artificielle
donc avec mon client n'a créé une
voiture je début il existe tout seul
tant qu elle
tout seul sait pas conduire on va lui
demander d'observer les automobilistes
d'apprendre de leur comportement et au
bout d'un moment la voiture pourrait se
lancer y conduire ça marchait pas mal an
j'étais assez fier après j'avoue j'avoue
que la première fois qu'on l'a testée et
qu'on s'est retrouvés à 110 km heure sur
une route de montagne
on s'est vite peut-être peut-être il y
avait des comportements de conduite a
pas reproduire moi j'ai corrigé
l'algorithme est là il ya une entreprise
qui arrive et qui s'est aperçu qu'en
fait j'ai été à l'origine d'une
intelligence artificielle qui détecte
automatiquement les bons et les mauvais
conducteurs
donc en fait j'étais à l'origine d'une
intelligence artificielle qui analyse
non pas les situations mais les
individus
exactement ce que j'essayais de pas
faire et ça ça avait été ma deuxième
leçon
l'intelligence artificielle elle est pas
neutre même quand on la développe et
qu'on pense que c'est dans un but noble
un bon mois de 15 ans à la plage je le
voyais quoi là non ça a été détourné il
a été dévoyé techniquement rien n'a
changé et vous savez quoi au même moment
ils les premiers scandales de
l'intelligence artificielle
et notamment les intelligences
artificielles raciste
sa vie quand on vit dans un monde où une
intelligence artificielle envoyer des
gens en prison juste parce qu'il était
noir
l'intelligence artificielle elle observe
et elle reproduit nos biais de sociétés
pour le veuille ou non aujourd'hui à
quelque chose qui s'appelle les
inégalités salariales entre les femmes
et les hommes
l'intelligence artificielle l'a observé
l'intelligence artificielle la reproduit
et comme chercher un emploi
vous tapez votre intitulé de postes sur
votre moteur de recherche est fortes
chances pour que ça fasse remonter une
offre avec un salaire plus élevé c'est
un homme derrière le clavier
l'intelligence artificielle à l'observer
elle reproduit nos billets de société
c'est ce qui arrivé à amazon ya pas très
longtemps amazon qui est au coeur de
tous les débats aujourd'hui visiblement
fait des gestes c'est bon amazon plus
grosses boîtes de teck et c'est un des
gars files étaient en train de
développer un algorithme l'intelligence
artificielle de recrutement pour les
aider à sélectionner les meilleurs cv
des candidats pour un poste de teck
vous savez quoi il ya tellement peu de
femmes dans la tech que le profil idéal
c'était un homme et amazon je le répète
un des caf à une des plus grosses boîtes
de tech etc sont retrouvés a développé
un algorithme de recrutement qui
disqualifie automatiquement toutes les
candidatures féminines
l'intelligence artificielle
si elle voit de la discrimination elles
valent à reproduire
elle va l'amplifier elle va la justifier
puis des fois juste
les algorithmes de reconnaissance
faciale technologie extraordinaire très
utilisée aujourd'hui les plus gros
acteurs américains du marché sont des
solutions qui marchent très bien sûr les
caucasiens
pas très bien sur les autres je vous
parle de moins de 1 % d'erreurs pour un
homme blanc a jusqu'à 36% derrère pour
une femme noire c'est des technologies
qui sont utilisés dans les processus de
recrutement vidéo vous venez pour passer
un entretien c'est un entretien vidéo si
vous êtes une femme noire
une fois sur trois l'algorithme niveau
reconnaît juste pas alors comment ça se
fait ça chez un petit peu d'où vient le
problème
je voulais illustrer avec un autre
exemple qui est google à quelques années
ils ont lancé le google d'ibm dream
c'était l'intelligence artificielle qui
reconnaissait des formes dans des images
des premières utilisations du diplôme
il avait entraîné cette intelligence
artificielle sur un jeu de données
composée exclusivement de chiens
des chiens 120 races de chiens quand on
utilisait cette intelligence
artificielle pour reconnaître des formes
disons dans la nébuleuse karine a vu par
le télescope hubble pas ça voyez des
chiens exactement ce qu'on lui a demandé
de faire on lui a donné des chiens va
demander la prendre à reconnaître des
chiens il reconnaît qu' chien ces
extrêmes mais c'est pareil avec les
hommes blancs sur la reconnaissance
faciale algorithmes il a vu un jeu de
données qui est absolument pas
diversifié il a reproduit
ça moi j'appelle ça de la discrimination
stupide
stupide parce que c'est même pas le
reflet d'une inégalité de société
stupide parce que c'est juste le reflet
du profond déséquilibre dans les données
d'apprentissage discrimination tupi sauf
que c'est super facile à atteindre
honnêtement suffit de passe est trop
posé la question on entend souvent que
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
reflet de celui qui l'a code
bon ben non je suis femme féministe eut
engagé
j'estime être quelqu'un de bien y a pas
de risque non c'est faux c'est faux
c'est complètement faux la
discrimination n'est pas dans les doigts
qui tape sur un clavier c'est
complètement faux la discrimination
elle est dans les données qu'on fournit
à l'algorithme
d'accord
c'est vrai j'avoue qu'en tant que
l'expert de l'intelligence artificielle
on a eu tendance ces dernières années à
se dire que c'est tellement compliqué ce
qu'on essaye de faire que finalement on
fait avec ce qu'on a
elle est là notre responsabilité n'a pas
le droit de se contenter de ce qu'ils
facile à obtenir
c'est la dernière leçon intelligence
artificielle n'est pas neutre elle peut
être raciste elle peut être sexiste elle
peut être injuste
par contre on peut la contrôler on peut
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
discrimination
il ya des outils qui existent
aujourd'hui pour détecter
automatiquement la discrimination dans
l'intelligence artificielle la recherche
a avancé on est capable de corriger la
discrimination avant l'apprentissage de
l'algorithme
on a tous une part de responsabilité pas
que les
lauper
on est tous là on soit ils peuvent qu on
utilise le lien on consomme de
l'intelligence artificielle tous les
jours et c'est notre responsabilité à
tous mathématicien data scientist
développeurs donneurs d'ordres citoyens
de s'assurer que l'intelligence
artificielle
elles servent réellement à construire
une société numérique plus juste vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]